american people this was a poll that
came out i know you love polls
this is a poll that came out this is a
poll that came out that said in 1970
during the walter cronkite era
80 percent of the american people
trusted the media
that same poll that came out said 20
of people trusted the media today you've
been around
what's changed in the last 50 years yeah
a couple of things have changed the more
important thing is
people's views of their government you
know
you know we talk about the kennedy era
you know
as this shining moment like camelot
under king arthur and obviously that's a
myth
but one thing that is true it used to be
70 75 80 percent of the american people
thought that their government most of
the time
worked for them now we're down to 20
of the american people believing that
so both the media and the government
have collapsed in terms
of public trust and this is a
huge crisis for our democracy because if
people can't believe in reliable sources
of information
and people can't believe in
long-established institutions
then our democracy is in a lot of
trouble and you know because you've had
experience abroad
democracies are fragile you know we tend
to believe oh
american democracy can never collapse
but you know as well as i
in the great era first great golden age
of democracy after world war one there
were dozens of democracies
by the mid-1940s we were down to 12.
so and according to freedom house in the
last
10 or 15 years 25 democracies
they haven't become complete autocracies
but they have greatly declined
in their democratic strength
so is that is that something so if
you're saying right now
that when it comes down to the democracy
you know with 20
we don't trust the media nor do we trust
the government i'm not sure it's 20
percent but
let's i think it's higher than that i
think it's more like
40 but let's just say we don't i mean is
that a good thing or a bad thing and if
it's a bad thing
who do we trust who do the american
people lean on trusting uh
to give the right source well
you know what what's happened
unfortunately is
people tend to trust the media that
echoes
their own views those who watch fox news
are fundamentally different
than those who uh watched msnbc
and while these are all long-term trends
all these trends has been greatly
exacerbated by donald trump
you know richard nixon famously said the
media is the enemy of the people right
but he said it in private
people don't realize he never said that
in public trump has had
said that dozens of times in public and
has tweeted
attacks on the media over 1500 times
since he took office and we know the
ways in which he has been
divisive racially gender
religion so we've had a president who
loves chaos
and loves division and that's been a
huge problem